>> Good morning, everyone.
Thank you so much for coming.
My name is Tom Zimmermann,
I'm a researcher in
the RiSE Group at MSR,
and it's my pleasure to
introduce Andreas Zeller,
who is a full professor at
Saarland University in Germany.
And he was actually
my PhD adviser,
so I'm really looking
forward to a talk.
Andreas is one of
the top people in
software engineering research.
He is an ACM fellow.
He won several Most Influential
Paper Awards for his work
on mining software repositories
and automated debugging.
In recent years, he has
done much more on security,
and we are looking
forward to your talk.
>>Thank you, Tom.
Thank you very much.
I was making jokes
because I became
ACM fellow for our work on
mining software repositories,
among others, OK.
Yes, that's great.
It's always nice to come
back to the Seattle area.
I just noted that it's now
18 years ago since I came here
the first time and it's amazing
how much things have
changed since then.
I was strolling through
the city yesterday and I
found that the Alaskan highway
is now ripe for demolition,
which people were talking
about 18 years ago.
It's nice to see the new
520 bridge now in operation,
which people were talking
about 18 years ago.
>>The hardware is pretty
much the software.
>>And I understand that
in only seven years,
there will be
an extension to Microsoft.
We will see, we'll see.
Before I retire, I will see
all the beautiful things
that people have been talking
about all these years.
>> You must plan the work.
>>The place where I come
from so this is
Germany over here,
and this little pixel,
two times two pixel thing here,
this is the state of Saarland
and this the City
of Saarbrucken.
Well, I also arrived
there 16 years ago,
and we've had no new bridges
or no new - oh,
we got a new light rail.
Yes, but it has
two new stations, too,
very much like
the one over here.
But, the place actually,
but things don't
change that much.
It's fine and it's good
because things are
good as they are.
Although there is
one particular point
where things do change,
and if you haven't been to
Saarbrucken for some time,
this is our newest building
in computer science.
This is our, oh I
think it should be,
our tenth building or so
that we're getting there.
This is an all new center for
IT security and
earlier this year,
it has been announced
that this center is going
to be expanded massively.
Right now, there's
about 100 researchers in there.
It's going to expand to
500 researchers in the course
of the next 10 years.
Meaning that, right now,
we're having one application
talk every week and it's
going to remain that way for
the next 10 years, which is fun.
If you have any friend who,
for some reason, doesn't like
to go to Microsoft Research,
which is also what I
recommend to my students,
and who likes work in security,
ask them to check us out.
It's a very dynamic
place to be in.
What I'm doing there is,
among others, the work
that I'm presenting today.
This is "Mining Input Grammars
for Security Testing".
Although this is a bit, well,
this is not the best title
for this talk,
as I realized, unfortunately,
only yesterday because
a much better title
for this talk would be
something like "Making $50,000
a Month by Fuzzing Software".
And now that I have
your attention,
the money is a great motivator,
let me tell you how
we're doing this.
Fuzzing is what most of
you know I very much suppose,
is the idea of feeding
programs with random input
at the system level.
This is Bart Miller who invented
the term and
the technique in 1989,
and the paper
today is a classic,
"An Empirical Study of the
Reliability of UNIX Utilities",
where Barton and
his students went along
and created random inputs,
fed them into the Unix
utilities at the time and
saw them crashing and
hanging and actually,
a very wide number,
25 to 33 percent of them,
because they were
never ever subject
to such inputs before,
actually crashed and hanged.
This is a typical output
of a Fuzzer.
It's very easy to
build a Fuzzer.
Actually, that's
five lines of Python code,
which will happily produce code,
which will happily
produce inputs like these.
I'm sure there is
a programming language where
this is actually
a valid program.
>> It's called shots.
>>Yeah, not exactly sure.
Maybe we should, maybe we can
fit this into
a Perl interpreter of
sorts or something
else but the thing is,
there will be lines in there,
which simply are very long
so programs are prone
to buffer overflows.
Anything that parses
things will check, say,
for strings, for
a beginning of a string,
end of a string so there's
many ways that programs can
fail simply by
scanning this input.
And at the time, yes,
plenty of different utilities
on the various Unix
flavors of the time,
on Sun, on Solaris, on IBM,
and so on, all happily failed.
Actually, the nice exception
to the rule was the GNU tools,
which already
existed at the time.
They turned out to be
the most robust ones,
and this is also
the base for the tools
we have today on Linux.
Since then, of course,
1989 has been a long time,
anyone now knows how
to fuzz a program.
The reliability
has much improved.
Today, it's actually
pretty hard to
get any of these systems
to crash if you use
the same technique
as Bart Miller did in 1989
but the thing is that
parsers that we have today,
that are written
today, are much more
robust than the parsers
we had in 1989,
where people only began to
imagine that they could be
some weird input that
feeds into one's program.
The problem is that
a well-written parser will
happily reject all
invalid input as invalid,
and you will never ever reach
the code that actually
matters to you,
namely the runtime system,
the deeper layers that
can be beyond the parse,
where you would like to find
bugs or whether you'd
like to find successes.
However, if you do have
a syntactically valid input,
that is, an input
that is actually
processed by the parser,
then you have a chance
to discover bugs in
those later stages that happened
that then process the input
as parsed by the parser.
In order to get such a
syntactically valid input,
what we need is
a description of what
makes a valid input.
This is called the input
language of the program,
and we all know
there's language theory
for that and what we can do is,
we can create a grammar that
describes the input structure,
the syntactic rules
of the input,
and using this grammar,
we can then produce
a syntactically correct input.
This is something we did,
a student of mine in 2012.
Now, that's five years ago.
My student, Christian Holler,
built this whole thing
for JavaScript.
He built a JavaScript grammar,
which actually was quite
some work writing this down.
Using this JavaScript grammar,
which he created,
his tool would
then happily create
inputs that are indeed valid
JavaScript and feed these to
JavaScript parsers
such as the one that is
found in Firefox or in Chrome.
This input, as you
see it over here,
was one of the first inputs
that actually crashed
the parser or that crashed
the JavaScript interpreter,
which actually is a serious
thing because if you can
manage to crash an interpreter
or the JavaScript interpreter,
this typically is the base
for a later exploit.
If you have an exploit in
the JavaScript interpreter,
that's very serious
because this means that you
can take over the entire browser
and then collect
arbitrary data from the user.
Browsers today are like
operating systems so we get
full control of everything.
>> The interesting thing
about the work
of Christian, this fuzzer,
was that it not only would it
produce arbitrary random inputs,
you could also use
the very same parser to
parse existing
JavaScript programs,
of which there were many.
And to top it all off,
he used his parser to parse
existing JavaScript
programs from
bug reports which were known
to have caused troubles
before and he used them
to parse them and then
to recombine them.
So in a way he was looking
at reports of, say,
the measles and cholera,
parsed these two,
recombined them and created
new strains and feed all of
these to the
interpreter in the hope
of triggering new bugs
which was lots of fun.
It also was very successful.
Over the course of nine months,
he got 18 Chromium
Security awards,
12 Mozilla Bug Bounty
awards from
Google and Mozilla respectively.
And more specifically,
he gained $50,000
in bug bounties in
the first four weeks
of running his tool.
Running his tool on
a single machine, on a laptop.
So we're not even talking about
a server farm or anything.
And this is him,
this is Christian.
After these four weeks,
so you get to the top of
all the security leaderboards
and everything so that was fun,
he got hired away by Mozilla
at a quite nice salary.
It's not $50,000 a month
but it's steady, it's fun.
And his job description
was simply to
continue to run his tool.
That was fun.
So he's running his tool
for five years now.
He's perfecting it.
In these five years, no, sorry.
Since- well, that's
one year ago.
So one year ago when
I last asked him,
his tool had found 4,000 bugs,
had found 4,000 bugs in
the JavaScript interpreters
of Firefox and Chrome,
all of these bugs are
confirmed by developers, fixed.
So all the shebang,
all is there.
By the way, Mozilla gave him
the authorization to
still run his tool on
Chrome and he still gets
bug bounties once a
while as a side business.
So he gets a steady income
from Mozilla and he gets
the bug bounties from Chrome
the backbone so he's
perfectly at ease.
>> Trigger buffer overruns?
>> Yes, this is buffer overruns,
this is all sorts
of ways to cause the interpreter
to hang or to crash.
So it's buffer overruns,
it's bugs in
the optimization stages,
just-in-time
compiler, everything.
And as I said,
the largest success comes
from the fact that his tool
is able to parse
existing bug reports and
existing inputs
and recombine them.
So not only are his inputs
not completely
random but actually
there's a stronger resemblance
to existing code,
that's one thing.
And the second thing
is that if you
search in the vicinity
of existing bugs,
you're likely to find
more bugs because as we know
bug fixes aren't always perfect.
Sometimes they treat
more the symptom
than the cause and if you
search in the vicinity,
you're going to find more.
This is what made his tool
particularly successful.
When a taxi driver asks me,
so what do you do for a living?
I'm a professor.
So you're running from my
taxpayers money and everything,
so have you already done
something where you
can pay things back?
Okay. You, at Microsoft,
get asked this all the time
but for me this is rather weird,
then I can ask this taxi driver,
so which browser are you using?
Oh, I'm using Firefox and
I can go, yes, you know,
it's because of my- the fact
that you can use
Firefox and it's all
safe is well to some extent,
to quite some extent
actually due
to our work with
my student at the time.
And then he's very happy
and everything is settled.
So this is work that's
already a couple of years ago.
It was very nice, we loved it
and also had
a nice paper out of it.
So in principle one
could do this for every program
but the problem is that, well,
you need a grammar in
the first place and creating
such a grammar for a
for a non-trivial input,
most inputs are non-trivial,
it's actually quite some work.
For Christian, it took
him three months to
create this JavaScript grammar.
Actually, if you want to have
a real working grammar for
C programs for instance
just in order to do
some refactoring work or like
things such that you have
a good parser for it,
that's actually something
quite expensive.
I think you have
to shell out about
$10,000 for a single license
for a good C grammar
for instance.
Yes?
>> But in some sense,
you don't need
a really good grammar,
you just need
a good enough grammar.
So you could write
a grammar that is much more
permissive than it needs
to be and rely on a real parser
to allow that [inaudible].
>> To some extent, yes.
If you want to
have a grammar that
simply produces lots
of JavaScript code,
you can deal with a grammar
that only deals with a subset
of JavaScript for instance.
But if you want
the very same grammar to
parse the existing inputs
and to recombine them,
it really needs to go down to
the tiniest details
in order to be
able to process all the-
>> You could always use
that real parser to filter out-
>> That's right. That's right.
So there's two things in here.
So your grammar may
over approximate that
is it may produce
more inputs that are
actually not valid
JavaScript then in this
particular setting of fuzzing.
Well you're going to
live with whatever 20%,
50% of inputs that will
simply be rejected so
that's all there is.
You're just wasting
a bit of time.
But if you have a grammar
that under approximates,
you're going to miss out
a couple of features which will
not be tested and then you will
miss all the bugs
that are in there.
So that's the downside
of the whole thing.
So there's these two sides.
But then we're
talking about context
free grammars here anyway,
and Javascript has plenty of
context sensitive features
as any programming language.
Actually, Christian
also did a couple
of tricks in order to
deal with identifiers
and others in order to have
the parser accept more input.
So, what we started to
reason about at the time was
the idea of whether
it would be possible
to learn such grammars given
not only a set of samples.
There's a couple of works to
do that using machine
learning but actually
using the program at hand that
processes those inputs
in order to
learn how it's inputs
are structured.
And the way we built
it is as follows.
We do have a set of inputs
which can be a very small set.
Actually, we're aiming to get
this set to be the empty set.
We feed these inputs
to a program.
We observe how the program
processes these inputs,
we do this dynamically.
We have a tool called autogram,
which observes how
the program processes
those inputs and out of
these observations it
produces a grammar.
This grammar can then
be fed into a parser.
which then happily will
create more inputs towards
the program thus
creating in the end
a virtual circle where
you learn more and more
about the grammar and
the program itself.
So how does this work?
Think of a program
that processes a very simple
input, let's say, URLs.
We all know what
URLs are made of
and the idea is as follows.
A URL is made out
of different parts.
We do have a protocol.
We do have the hostname.
We do have a port.
We do have a login.
People, you should
not use logins in URLs
because they're transmitted
in the clear but,
well, they provide this,
and there's also path.
So these are standard
elements and we do have
a couple of separators in there.
And all of these elements
while they are being
processed by the program
that processes a URL,
all of these
individual fragments
go through different paths
and execution.
So the protocol, for instance,
the protocol is being used to to
determine what is
going to be parsed,
how the rest is
going to be parsed.
The hostname is
going to end up in
some DNS resolver function
that is going to
return us an IP address to which
we are going to connect
using the given port.
And then over that connection,
we're going to send out
the login as well
as the page request.
And all of these data,
all of these little fragments
go through different paths
through the execution
and they end
up in different functions.
And this idea that there
is a natural separation of
concerns in the program
execution that corresponds
to the structure in the input
is what we want to exploit.
So all of these
different functions,
for each fragment
different functions that are
stored in different variables,
this is the basic idea
where we want to
be able to extract
the structure of the grammar.
So, how can we do that?
Essentially we have
explored two ways.
One very thorough one
and one very simple one.
The first technique that we
looked at is to use dynamic
tainting which
essentially dynamically
during execution
attaches a label,
a tag, to individual data
as elements as they're
being processed.
And this tag propagates
along the computation.
So for instance, and this tag in
our case labels all the inputs
with their origin,
that is the input source and
the position in the input.
So for instance, we can
track where the port goes
to and even if the port
gets converted to a number,
the number inherits the tag of
the string and the port
then carries that,
take over to the function so
we can track all of these.
We can track all of
these inputs down.
The second technique
is much simpler.
This simply consists of
taking a memory dump at
a particular point in time.
And simply looking for
all string variables,
whether any of
the string variables
contain some characters
that also happened to occur
in the original input.
This is much simpler,
it's much cruder.
There's also room
for error in there,
but it turns out that
the latter one is something that
one can actually implement
much easier than the first one.
And I had some fun
a couple of weeks
ago implementing
the second technique in Python.
In Python, tracking a variable
is very- in tracking- sorry.
In Python,
accessing memory
during execution
is a very simple exercise.
You do have a function that
is called settrace and you
pass this- and you have
this API call settrace
and you pass it to function
which is called traceit.
And this traceit function
is going to be
called for every
single line that is
executed and every line
you get past the current frame,
the current event.
Meaning that a new line has been
execute as well as
other information.
And in the current frame
you can then look
up all the local variables and
all of their values as Python
elements. It's very simple.
So actually writing
a debugger in
Python is 12 lines of code.
Okay? So, compare
that to Java or C,
it's no fun at all.
In Python, dynamic
analysis is a breeze.
And what we do is we access
all the local variables,
we access all of the values
and then we simply
check for the values.
If it's a string and if it
has two characters or more,
and if this value also
occurs in the input
that we've seen,
then we simply store
the variable that we have.
Store the variable and the value
that we have just seen.
So we just track these.
And let me show you how
this works in a real code.
So here's the very
same code again.
I do have a function
which is your URL parse.
I do have a couple of inputs
which are passed to them.
And very down here,
I should have
precisely the function
that we have just seen.
So I'm using this
trace function thing.
Where is it again?
So one second. Here we go.
So this is the set
tracing function.
I am producing some output
and for every value
I'm saving it
and accessing the
individual variables and I'm
saving those that also
occur in the input.
Now, to run this
on your URL parse,
this is precisely what I get.
So I get that during
your URL path,
a function which I
have not implemented,
which I have never seen.
Actually, this would be
something I've never
looked into that,
there's a variable called
URL which holds the path.
This is one part of the input.
There is a variable
named fragment
which lo and behold
it's the fragment.
There is a variable called
scheme which happens
to be the scheme.
There is a variable
called netloc which holds
the host and the port.
Which is precisely what
we have over here.
And there there's a path which
is very much like the URL
also holds this
very path over here.
And I can now go and
also apply this to
other inputs just
for the fun of it.
Where I will, if you let me,
make this the first input.
So here I am happy
lurking along.
So here's another URL and
here we also have a scheme
which now is HTTPs and
we do have a netloc,
again, a location which
also occurs in here.
So you can see that simply
by looking at the variables,
I can already extract
the individual
lexical items as they
occur in the input.
So from this I can
now go and infer
and use this knowledge
that the input is
decomposed into these variables
to derive a grammar.
Namely in two steps,
I start with a very simple
grammar that simply says,
"My grammar consists of
precisely this input."
This is very trivial,
anybody can write
example like this.
Then you create a disjunction
over multiple inserts and
it's all very simple.
That's not how you do it.
Okay, well. And what we do then,
no grammar inference can
be a very easy thing.
It's actually
100% sound, so it's cool.
Every string in that grammar
is a valid input.
So and then what I do is I go,
and for each and every variable
I see,I introduce
the rule by replacing
all the occurrences
of that value by
a non-terminal and
then I say this
non-terminal expands to
the appropriate value.
Let's try that out with
the values that we've just seen.
So here's my initial grammar.
Here we go. Now I
apply the second rule.
I go and all of
these variables I introduce
appropriate new rules.
So let's start with
netloc for instance.
netloc, this is this one.
So I'm going to replace
this string as it occurs up
here by the netloc.
So this is what I get.
So now I have
this expansion to netloc
and I see what
netloc is in here.
I can do the same
for the scheme.
I can repeat the same
thing, for the path,
for the fragment
as well as finally
for this URL variable which
doesn't really belong here.
I guess, it's
some sort of misnomer,
but that's what you get.
And if I do this again then I
see that the path
is in fact a URL.
Under URL there's path.
All these names are well-chosen
except for the URL one.
I have no idea what the folks in
URL parse thought of when
they gave this
variable this name.
But what you can see
here now is how we have
decompose this grammar input
into a nice of things.
So our URL starts with
a scheme followed by location,
followed by a path,
followed by a fragment.
Now, this is just for
one single input, okay?
And of course I
want to extend this
to multiple inputs. Yes.
>> [inaudible] for
example if the user had
capitalized all the URLs?
>> Yes, yes, yes. I'll
come to that in a second.
Wait a moment.
We'll definitely expand
this whole thing, okay?
So this is just for
one single input
and this is just
one decomposition,
the one decomposition
we've seen for that input.
Now the idea is
that I can go and
do this for multiple
inputs, sorry.
And for multiple inputs,
what I'm going to- Actually
I have implemented
this whole thing.
So here we go.
And if we implement
this and if we run this,
this's precisely
the grammar that we get.
So this is just
live here in Python.
Note that this is a fully
self-contained Python program
and we are at like 200 here.
So it took me
four hours to design it,
to build it, and to
quality control it.
So that was something that
was not very hard to do
and this was very annoying
for my student who had
spent a year building
this whole thing for Java,
but his work is much more
sophisticated than the very
crude thing I'm
having over here.
Now the interesting thing is
that I can repeat this thing for
multiple inputs and I
can easily merge
these grammars together.
And since I have the structure
I can merge them by rule.
So for every single rule
that I have,
I'm simply going to
add a disjunction
for the next value that I see
which actually represents
the individual variables,
the individual values that
their respective
variable can take.
So if I do that I am going
to spare you the code for that.
This is not very nice code,
but I'm simply
going to run that.
So what I have done now
here is I have taken
three inputs with
different schemes for instance.
And how you see, here
is the disjunction,
it's HTTP or HTTPS and
the fragment variables one
is ref and one is ref2.
And the host of course can take
different values and the query,
we have now other query.
This is one of the inputs.
Well, there's only
just one variable here.
So we have a path that
has taken the value
/path and /bar.
And over here we see the
various schemes that there are.
So we see that you
can have something.
With a fragment you
Without a fragment,
you can have something.
With a query and a fragment.
So these are different
expansions and if
I would add
some syntactic sugar,
I could go and say
that the query in
here and the fragment
are actually both optional.
Now if I have such a grammar
and indeed I can start
with this very grammar,
I can immediately use
this for producing
various combinations which then
gives us various combinations
of the little constituents.
And then I can create
arbitrary combinations of hosts,
and paths,
and references and for
some reason no query in here.
Good. I'm going to-
where's with the query?
Oh yes, hasn't expanded.
Let's try that again.
Do we see a query?
No query. How come?
Good. Here we go.
Again, another combination.
So every time I can
use this roll the dice,
use an arbitrary
extension writing
a producer for a given grammar.
Again, this is
eight lines of code.
Not very complicated.
Okay. And of course the more
elaborated my grammar gets,
the more alternatives I have and
the more possibilities
for combination follow.
So as I said, this is
a very simple program.
We use these programs
for teaching.
I'm having a course
on security testing,
the next one starts
mid-October and we are
indeed showing folks how to
create such grammars and
how to mine such grammars.
This is the very program
we're giving out to
students such that they can then
try out and see
how it works. Now-
>>This is just a very
simple version, okay?
There is still lots
and lots of pieces
missing but it is clear that
there's ways to
further expand this and
we now get to
our real implementation,
the one that my student
took a year for.
This is now for
a real programming language,
so we are working with Java.
I never try to submit
a paper where I am saying,
this works beautifully on
these 20 lines of this,
or these 10 lines of Python.
For some reason, it has to be
this big Java program
or this big C program,
so I am always fearing
that if I submit something
that works on Python,
people will not
take it seriously.
So, we built this whole thing
for Java and it has
a full grammar inference
of Java programs.
This is actually
the first technique
ever that is able to mine
input grammars from programs.
What we did have before was
mining such grammar
from samples,
which is very nice.
Google has implemented
quite a number
of machine learning techniques
that tell you that,
if in a period after command
you have this token and
this other token then typically
this next token is
going to follow,
and you can create
valid documents with that.
The problem though, is that this
is not going to tell you well,
it is only going to give you
those documents
that look realistic,
but it is not going to
give you documents that
explore all the other
possibilities that
are in the program.
>> Which paper if
Google does that?
>> Google does that, yes.
>> Which paper is that?
>> I don't know whether they
have a paper but I spoke to
Domagoj Babic at Google.
I was not under NDA
and he told me that.
>> [inaudible]
>>And there is work
with Patrice Godefroid.
Yes. Machine learning for
[inaudible] , yes sure.
So you have the same paper.
I think they never bothered
to write a paper about it.
And also there is people at
Stanford also that
appeared this year at PLDI,
where people have a great
technique for inferring grammars
using some active learning
of the program but our idea
is to have the program as
a reference so extract
the grammar for it,
not samples, nothing,
as little as possible.
Our Java implementation
uses dynamic tainting,
so we don't look
at memory dumps,
we simply follow our characters.
We also do some active learning
to check for repetitions
and optional parts, that is,
for each and
every grammar element,
we actually go and
find out what happens
if we leave that out.
And if this still
the result in a valid input,
if the program under test still
accepts this, we
know it is optional.
For every element, we try
repetitions and if it
accepts multiple repetitions,
we know we can repeat it.
That's fine too,
and very nice too.
We do have a number of
predefined lexical items such as,
numbers and others
which we identify,
so these are
regular expressions,
and if we find out
that some input
matches a regular expression,
say such as a number,
we try out more numbers and
if we find that more numbers
are also matched,
we know that this is a number,
and we also have a hierarchy
of these expressions.
We have natural numbers and next
coming up is negative numbers.
This is how we find out
that the port number,
for instance, only can
be a natural number
but cannot be a negative number.
I have no idea what
happens if you pass
a negative port number or
whatever is going to happen.
I remember that if you kill
a negative process on Unix,
if you kill a process and
give it negative process ID,
the entire group is going to
collapse but no idea
what happens if you
open a negative port.
Anyway, we now know,
from our work, that ports
cannot be negative in URL.
I am going to
give you a couple of examples
of what this
actually looks like.
So, this is again a URL example,
but now with our autogram
prototype applied on
the Java net URL parser and
this is the grammar
that pops out of it.
This is the raw output
of our tool.
We just as in
the Python example that
I have shown you before,
we make use of
actual variable names and
function names in order to
make this other readable.
And here you can
see what is URL?
A URL starts with a spec
and there is a string in
the beginning and this string is
a protocol followed by
an authority as well
as by an optional path.
Your authority consists
of an optional password,
at a host, the host
is mandatory,
followed by an optional port.
The protocol in our example
here is always HTTP.
The user info is a given
but the host is a hostname.
The port is
a sequence of digits.
The path is actually a path.
A query and references are
all alphanumeric characters with
special characters in there.
And this is what we learn from
this one single example only.
So, simply by looking at
this one single example,
which now has a couple of
features and generalizing
over it and finding out
which parts are optional,
finding out which parts
can be repeated,
we get all the
generalizations that
we get in this anti grammar.
>> The protocols that are not
[inaudible] they are false,
have you do some kind
of checking options?
>> The protocol is something we
cannot generalize
because our tool
has no knowledge
about HTTP protocols.
If it had knowledge
about protocols,
then I think it would be
cheating at some point.
We can generalize over
individual protocols,
what we can find out is
that we cannot
generalize protocol
to an arbitrary strain
because arbitrary strings
would not be accepted.
But we cannot find out
that other protocols,
say like HTTPS or file or
something would be accepted.
We would need
extra inputs for that.
The reason for that is simple.
The way the Java URL net
empowers the work is,
for a given protocol,
if you pass that in,
it is going to look
whether there is any class
in the class loader that
matches the appropriate name,
and if there is a class,
it is going to load it and
then it is going to execute it.
Well, we cannot come up with
a neat and universal mechanism
that at some point would
search the file system for
Java files that make
specific file names.
So that is not something we can,
we do not know this.
But the other parts,
yes the path, the query,
reference and all of this
can all be systematically
expanded such that we know
which parts are actually
part of the grammar.
You had a question?
Not now? Yes.
>>When you are doing
that team tracking?
You're now looking at
the path of a thing,
like the control flow
of a thing.
>>We're not looking
at the control flow,
we're only looking
at the data flow.
Thing is, if we look
at the control flow,
if we look at control - It's
implicit information flow,
that would be the correct term.
Then, we would very quickly get,
and find out that everything
depends on everything,
and so we only look
at the data flow.
This has a limitation.
For instance,
this technique works
because the URL parser
is a handwritten parser.
If we apply this technique
say on the table driven parser,
such as a generator parser,
we would not be able to find
out that there is
information flow along
all this part or on
all these table elements
because all of these are
governed by implicit
information flow.
Generally, if you
have something like
switch and a character,
and then in case of
that character do that,
in case of the other
character do that,
you have a controlled dependency
and this is something where
we still have to
tune which kinds
of control dependencies we
want to look at and
which others we don't
want to look at.
But there is a couple
of expansions, which
goes into that direction.
On the other hand, If you do
have a table-driven parser,
chances are that you do have
a computer readable grammar in
the first place
because that's where
these table-driven parsers
are typically generated from.
I can give you another example.
This is actually
a Microsoft one.
This is INI files. This is
a Java parser for INI files,
and here we can
see, so INI files.
That's key value pairs with
an equal sign sections
in square brackets.
The essence is in here.
You have lines that
consist of sections
or key followed by
arbitrary number of blanks,
followed by a space,
followed by an optional value.
The key is not
optional, the value is.
I didn't know that you can
have something without values,
and all of this is in here,
and these lines then are
separated by new lines,
and they all are combined
into one single grammar.
You can see that this
is a bit convoluted.
You can see here
there's a first line,
that's first mean parse,
so there's a first section,
and here again we have
this section down here again.
That's because of the way
this INI file parser
is written,
and I should say it's
not very well written,
it looks like a crude scanner
but then these
individual elements
that are in the
implementation are also
reflected in our grammar
again but still,
with a bit of manual cleanup,
this becomes a very
beautiful grammar.
Here's my-
>>You do have
production patterns
in the sense -
I would have expected you
to generate things like,
it's either line 1,
line 2, line 3, line 4
or line 1, line
2, line 2, line 3
so you have away to pick
a sequence of lines and
generalize it to a line start.
>>Yes. This is what we do too.
This is a repetition
recognition,
and we can find out that
the input is valid
if we have no lines,
if we have one line,
and if we have multiple lines,
and this is how we can
then generalize that
there is a, is it a clean start?
I think it's a clean start.
So we can find out
that the elements can
be repeated arbitrary
number of time.
Likewise here for
the spaces and others.
This is my all favorite.
This is for JSON.
This is, again,
one single input so
one single sample suffices.
This is a constructed example
where we actually look for
various ways of
number formatting
because these make up
different parts in the parser.
Again, we feed this
into our autogram,
and this is the grammar
that comes out of it,
and I'm very much in
love with that grammar
because it's almost
text book quality.
You see, what is a JSON file?
The JSON file is the value, and
the value is either a string,
or false, or true,
or an object, an area,
a null, or a number.
A string is something
called a hash,
which is a bad name
but I'm happy with it,
something enclosed
in double quotes.
False and true are
false and true.
An object is a string,
a key value pair followed by
more optional key value pairs
as many as needed,
separated by commas and
with closing
parenthesis at the end.
An array is similar
except that we're using
a square brackets
here. Null is a null.
A number is an integer followed
by possible fraction
and exponent.
All of this is in there.
Again, this is what a tool
produces from
one single input, okay?
There's so many things
you can do with that.
You can use this immediately for
understanding what
the input is made of,
because we all know what
a JSON is so we understood.
We can see that
his grammar is valid,
but now imagine you have
some unknown file format
and this is what pops out,
or you can immediately
use this for fuzzing
because you can
immediately create tons and
tons of valid JSON inputs.
You can use this to compare
multiple versions of
the program against each other.
You take one JSON parser,
take another JSON parser,
you find out what
the difference between
the two grammars is so it gives
you plenty of insights
about how the input is,
about what the input looks
like, and what you
can do with it.
You have a question.
>>Yes. Terminals or
non-terminals, is that pulled from
like identifiers within the-.
>>All pulled from identifiers.
>>Mostly, there's some
alphanum with white space
or special white spaces.
>>The ones that are
underlined here,
alphanum with
special white space,
these are our predefined ones.
I just noticed that string
internal is not, this
is actually false.
This is part of
the grammar in here
but the ones that are
underlined in here,
this is true up here.
Integer here and
positive integer,
these should also be underlined.
These are our predefined ones.
We have a paper where
this is described.
This also come as part of
another grammar where all
of these are being defined.
We simply recognize that
something matches
this regular expression,
and then we know that this for
all the positive
integers that we
have generated actually holds,
and after a couple of I
think it's five trials,
after five trials we know well,
we've seen it work for 53,
for 4,700 and for three more,
then we assume it's
a positive integer.
We can also do
some Newton iteration
in order to find ranges
and other stuff that's all in
the works. You have a question.
>>Many things or types of
learned object definition.
>>Yes.
>>What is the is guideline if
you're trying to understand
and trying all possible
expressions in the grammar?
>>What we do for individual
element in one rule, okay?
For individual elements
in one rule,
we try to omit them and we
check whether the input
is still valid.
Let me just check. I think we
also do this for larger groups.
We first do this for
individual humans,
then for pairs, then
for triples and so on.
It takes some time so
this JSON inference
is a number of
a couple of minutes,
but well, you do it
once and then you have
it so there you go.
Yes.
>>What are you doing when
you obfuscate variable names?
Let's say someone uses
capture hoops or something
and then you have
arrays with, you know.
>> Then all of this
becomes X1, X2,
X3 and so on so we cannot
find these out either.
But, even so, the
simple fact that
it's not only the names
that make these readable,
it's also the structure
that follows from it
because you can
really see how this,
so if you look at
the JSON implementation,
this structure of
the grammar very nicely
reflects the structure of
the program that processes it
and you can obfuscate
lots of names, no problem.
If you start obfuscating
the structure of your program,
that process has inputs.
Plenty of programmers
who will work
with your code later on will
be extremely angry at you.
If you want to really
obfuscate things,
you also need to come up with
some mechanism, "Oh,
that's really bad."
You need to come
up with a mechanism
that not only obscures
the control flow but
actually that also
obscures all the data flow
in your program.
You would have to split
these things into multiple
variables, but, even so,
if you say I'm going to store
the first three characters in
one variable and the next
two characters another variable,
all that is going to show
up is that there's a rule in
here that say that false
is composed of two parts,
and the first is fal
and the second is
se so yeah, it's a web.
Right now, there should be ways
of obscuring this
but right now we're
rather interested in
bringing more light
into what's happening here.
These are just three examples
of a autogram tool,
and yes, we do have a couple of
exciting work that's
dealing with that.
Right now, we are
re-implementing
this whole thing for
C programs and the reason
for that is that we found
that our technique for
tagging the Java
elements and actually
changing their representation is
still something that
is very brittle.
Whenever we have a new subject
and particular more larger
and more complex subject,
we typically run into bugs in
the Java interpreter in
Java virtual machine.
We have many ways
of getting the Java
virtual machine to crash,
that very interesting,
but it doesn't help us
because we need to build
appropriate work around.
Now, we're building this
whole thing for C programs for
which we do have
nice interpreters and
instrumentation
infrastructures that are
way more solid plus there's
more interesting system level
utilities at the sea level.
Think of all the
operating system,
parts of the demons,
the protocols, all
the data exchanges,
all this is written
in C, so it's fun.
With this active learning,
we already can do with
a minimum of samples.
One single sample is great.
So we can explore
all the variations,
but in the long run,
we want to do this
without any samples at all.
So for JSON, we have,
we have for JSON,
and how do you say,
in a spike solution.
We have managed to create
a nice little test generator
that is oriented towards
the parsing technique that
is able to systematically
generate all the
different variations
of JSON, that was nice.
And now, we're generalizing
this towards more programs.
So, which means that
in the longer run,
you will be able to take
an arbitrary program,
feed this into our technique
and out pops the grammar.
This is the long-term goal
we're aiming for.
The fuzzing part, interestingly,
has lots and lots of
open issues because you want to
apply techniques from one
to play a couple of tricks
from test generation,
for instance you want
to fuzz in order to
get a maximum of code coverage
or feature coverage.
You want to, a simple thing,
covering all the
production rules, okay?
Again that's in
our Python fuzzer.
That's 30 minutes,
one hour of work.
And it turns out this
has not been done before,
but as soon as you
systematically try
out to come up with
all sorts of various
production rules,
you get a much better coverage
of the program.
And that's because
the grammars we're
having here and the functions,
that because the structure
of the program,
is reflected in the structure
of the grammars.
And so, if you cover
the structure of the grammar,
you're also going to
cover the structure of
the program. This
is very helpful.
Integration with
symbolic testing,
grammars on one side,
program semantics
on the other side.
How do you bring
these two together?
So what we can do,
and what one of
my students is working on,
is to create local solutions
with symbolic constraint solving
at the function level that
is determining how can
you reach a particular
behavior in the program.
So, solving those constraints,
and then finding out.
Well, this variable
which I need to have
this particular value down here
in that function in order
to achieve that goal,
is something that stems from
this element in the grammar,
because this something
we have established
earlier with and imitating.
So we can find out oh,
if you pass a minus
one down here, it's
going to crash.
We can lift that value back
to the grammar and see.
Well, let's put it
in minus one in here.
Maybe the minus one will
be rejected by the parser,
but at least that's worth a try.
And in the end, what
we want to build
is the world's best
fuzzing platform.
Yeah I'm competing
with the pros here.
I know that, but yes,
we want to build.
We want to bring all
of this together,
creating a platform where
you throw in a program,
where we can infer that in,
where we can infer
the structure of the input,
where we can apply
smart test generation techniques
based on the structure of
the input and then cover
as many features as possible
in a minimum amount of time.
And fortunately, I'm
not alone with that.
I do have a couple of
great post-docs and PhDs.
We do have a whole
group in it from
Oregon State University
student of Alex Gross
who's working with me
on the creative part of
the Nicholas, is
working with Nicholas.
Avakov is working on
creating the fuzzer.
Matyas has created the first
implementation of Autogram.
Alexander is working on
integration with
symbolic testing,
and Burin is doing all the work
on C programs these days.
This is the army of folks
who is helping with it.
I'd like to point out that
I wrote the Python programs.
So, you know, for
somebody who
increasingly relies on
others to write programs
and build stuff,
I would like to point
out that I also can
write stuff myself.
So, just to point that out,
just to point that out.
German professors
can write code too.
You are happy to analyze my
Python code for
whatever features.
Occasionally, I write stuff OK?
And in the long run, you
know that this is fun.
I looked at file formats
in Wikipedia.
There's a page that's
called file format.
There's a list of file format.
These are all the
file formats that are
documented somewhere
in Wikipedia.
There is about, I think
it's 1,000 different
file formats,
all possible three and
four letter combinations.
File extensions are written
in their JPEG format.
You don't know
everything under the sun.
Dotsie are download,
no idea what this is,
oh it's Google Chrome of course.
And we wanted to be able to
infer those formats
one after the other,
and then be able
to fuzz them all.
As I said this is
very simple question:
what is the input language
of a program?
This is a very simple question,
and it's awfully
under-researched.
It's a question that, well,
it's very fundamental
to all sorts of testing
and of course to
program understanding,
at least of data understanding,
but inferring this
automatically is something that
will at best a handful
of people who've undertaken
into the last decade.
And how can I leverage
this infrastructure
in order to cover,
understand, prevent
particular inputs
if have a parser force
but for particular inputs?
Then you can say, "Okay,
here's this legacy program
which has a couple
of vulnerabilities.
I'm going to
restrict its input to
only those inputs that I know
that are legal or
the other way around.
I know that specific inputs
are malicious.
I'm going to infer
grammar for this.
I'm going to explicitly
prevent them." There you go.
You don't even have to patch
the program for your whatever,
for your two-year-old
IOT device which
you bought at a cheap price
and which no longer
is maintained.
Well, at least you can
set up a filter for that.
All of this translate also into
better understanding of code
because if you know that
this part of code processes
this particular input,
well, you have
a deeper understanding
of what is going on.
And of course, this
also gives you an idea
about how to cover
specific behaviors,
how to understand behaviors.
There's hundreds of
open issues that it's
very easy to start
doing research.
If I can write a Python program
that infers a grammar in
four hours, you can do so.
I'm sure you folks can do so in
one hour including
learning Python.
So, please enjoy it all, okay.
And this gets me to
the end of my talk.
So, what have I shown?
I've shown you how
to use grammars
for fuzzing of
existing programs.
The obstacle to that
is getting a grammar
in the first place.
And I have shown you, well,
both the Python
prototype as well as
our Autogram prototype that
is able to infer
such grammars automatically,
and the current work
of my students
happily working on extending
this idea in various directions.
And there is plenty of research
opportunities around it,
and all of this can
actually be found
on our web page that
is devoted to Autogram.
You also find our most
recent technical report with
all the features on
active learning there.
So, was it fun?
It was my pleasure to present,
and I'm happy to take questions.
Thank you very much
for your attention.
>> Yes, Chris?
>> Really cool,
I really like the topic,
and the result is
kind of exciting.
My question is, inputs,
it seems like you focusing
mostly in input that is
human readable and often inputs,
whether it's file formats or
across the wire or binary,
typically, at least
in my experience,
writing the codecs
for these things,
they are not context-free.
>> Yes.
>> You'll have some
length encoded or layers
something like that.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes
>>Do you have a sense
of how well these types
of approaches would
work in trying to handle that
where the output is not
context-free grammar
but something else?
>> Yes. There's
two important issues in there.
The first one is
context, as you put it.
What we infer here is context
through grammars and there's
plenty of data formats.
Actually, in
most reasonable formats,
there is some amount of
context sensitivity in there.
You would normally not want
a context-sensitive grammar
to describe these.
You can say, for instance,
suppose you have a checksum
for instance, okay?
You do not want to describe
the checksum using a
context-sensitive grammar, okay?
You can do that
but that's not fun.
I mean you look at
regular expressions and say,
I'm not sure about that
but programmers love
regular expressions and for
100 regular expressions
you have one grammar,
one context-free
grammar that is.
I'm pretty sure that for
100 context-free grammars,
you have one context-sensitive
grammar and then we go up
the way to universal grammar
and Turing machines and whatnot.
The further up you go,
the less popular things are
and you don't want to write
this with a
context-sensitive grammar.
What we're working on is to
extend such context-free
grammars with constraints,
that tell you that one
particular item is the result of
this particular operation being
applied on this other item
and this operation is
something that we imagine
can actually be extracted
from code because
you can find out that
the length that is
being encoded in here,
actually comes from code
and is being checked
at this point,
so we can extract
these operations
and feed them and make
constraints out of them.
This is how you can then
represent constraints with
respect to checksums
and length and of
all these other container
formats and binary formats.
Actually,
I have a very nice
master thesis on
that where I'm
awaiting results soon,
which is specifically geared
towards checksums and input.
The second thing is
that what we need here,
what we have here is
actually multiple layers of
languages stacked upon each
other like in
media formats you have or
say like the ISO/OSI
networking model,
not sure whether this
is still in textbooks.
Let's say you have
a layer where describe
things in terms of
bits being processed,
you have a layer where
you think about these as
data packets and then
somewhere up there,
you have the application layer.
Same thing happens
with media containers.
You have a
representation where you
have little bits
with checksums and
lengths and then you have
another representation where
you actually talk about
the context of all these
individual frames
that are packaged in
here and our goal is to
bring these together,
not only and by having
multiple grammar.
We can have one grammar for
each layer that describes it,
but the concept of
so-called conjunctive grammars,
which is a mostly
theoretical result from
language theory but the idea is
that you can take
multiple constraints.
The idea is that not only
you have these junctions.
I'll tell you what
this can be I or B,
but you can also
have conjunctions.
You can tell this can be A or B
and it also has to fulfill
this other constraint and
the idea here is
that you can then
express that file has to
fulfill the constrains
that happen at
the bit level but also at
the application level and
all of these together.
You can have negations
in there actually,
then you get Boolean grammar.
Then you can say, an input
has to fulfill for this,
and this, and must
not be this, okay?
Then you can actually
combine things like,
this is a kind of input that
you'd like to avoid so you
have an explicit blacklist
for instance.
This is something that we have,
that where we think
of in the near future,
we'll be able to infer these.
The problem is
production because,
right now, if you only
have these junctions,
production is
a very simple thing.
As soon as you
have conjunctions,
you actually have to go into
string constraint solving and
others where you, in the end,
have to invoke something like
a humpy or Z three in order
to fulfill those constraints.
But, again, this is classical.
This is a classical
constraint solving.
We have tools for
that, we know how to do
that so it's not
out of the reach.
Two answers, two longer answers
to a two single question.
Yes?
>> The examples that you
show would had
been the proper way
with this thing, in the
first, in writing any grammar.
>> Sorry.
>> Would it have been
the proper way to deal
with these things
to write grammar in
the first place rather than
constructing that as you go?
>> Well, you know, even for
a simple thing as a URL,
writing a grammar can be
difficult because if
you write the grammar,
you start to reason about
what kind of characters
can be in the path?
What is the range of
the port? Can I omit the port?
What kind of characters
are allowed in
the password, okay?
This is the things that
make you think hard but it's
important to capture
these constraints
precisely because these are
precisely the things
you want to test,
and by having an automatic
learner, or in this case,
an active learner that
infers those things for
you by running tens of
thousands of experiments.
You get way more
information than what
you could ever do through
manual testing and probing.
Even for a symbol,
even for for something
where we think we
know how something is composed,
formalizing this is
actually manual work.
If you think about a format
that you do not know,
okay, and say some
proprietary data format.
I remember, I was working,
this was during my student term,
I was working with
a with some sort
of vector drawing program,
which had a
proprietary file format
in which everything was stored.
I had no idea what
this looked like.
I loaded this file into
my text editor and
the first characters
in that file were,
so you're trying to find
out the innards of a
such and such file
A, question mark.
It was an insult.
I mean it's like you abandon all
of you who enter here
or something like that.
Okay, so it is difficult.
Now, you think about,
somewhere there's a hard disk in
which somebody has stored
millions and millions of
pictures made with
that particular program on
a hard disk and you have
no idea what it is made of,
but if we can extract
the grammar for it,
then we will be able to
identify what it's
made of and actually,
if you think of
it, we can create
a universal XML converter,
take anything and
convert it to XML using
this very structure in the
grammar to use XML out of it,
and all of a sudden you
can reuse everything.
Yes, there's plenty
of uses for that.
>> People might want to replace
their current implementation,
their grammar- based
implementation that they get
off of your tools.
>> Well, if you have
a grammar then it's
easier to create
a parser again out of it.
It's obviously easy to-
also if you think
of it as an Oracle,
for instance, you can
use the grammar to check
whether the outputs
are valid for instance.
It's amazing that we as well,
computer scientists
love grammars, we do.
If you do one year of
studying computer science,
you do learn a bit
about grammars in
formal languages and
you need them later too.
But bringing
these things together,
here's my program and
here's the language.
Okay, so far, we've only
seen this from
the prospect of creating
a specification and
then implementing it
and creating a parser
automatically from
a written specification.
Yes, we know that this
is parser generator
but the other way around,
here's a program
what's its input?
That's a problem
that has never been
addressed before
and I'm not even
sure whether the problem
has been posed before
and I think the problem has not
been posed before
because so far.
Even though the answer
is relatively simple,
it simply was not
obvious how to do that.
The thing is if you apply
standard static symbolic
techniques and have a parse.
If you have a parser
and you want to find
out what it does using
standard static
symbolic techniques.
You ever looked at
a generated parser
with its tables and everything,
it's impossible
to understand what
it does and also
for constraints,
it's impossible because if you
have a table with
10,000 entries,
you're going to end up with
a constraint that has 10,000
entries until the solution
is lo and behold the grammar.
So there was
no such thing and only
by using a dynamic
technique I think,
by looking at what's
actually happening during
the execution and combining this
with active learning and
testing this is how we can know.
Now, we have a good grip on
how things and how to
tackle that problem.
It's still going
to be a decade of
research until it all
works out and there's
plenty of opportunities so
I'm happy to encourage you all
to try these things
out for yourself.
>> Okay. So let's thank
Andreas one more time.
>> Pleasure.